so let's fight a vicious media attacks
and many political obstacles well 2017
was a very successful first year for
President Trump now before we get to the
full list that the media will never show
you let's take a look at the economy
stock market is at an all-time high and
hit over 60 record closes in 2017 alone
the Dow Jones was up 25% over five
trillion dollars in new wealth has now
been created unemployment yes
unemployment at a 17-year low sits at
just 4.1 percent and since taking office
President Trump has created 1.7 million
new jobs african-american unemployment a
17-year low we ended the year with
consumer confidence sitting at a 17-year
high home prices are up 6 percent as his
home building regulations about have
slashed at a historic rate and the Trump
administration cut 16 regulations for
every new one that was created also
let's talk about GDP now so far in the
President Trump we have seen two
quarters over 3 percent let's compare
that with President Barack Obama the
only president in the history of this
country to never reach 3 percent GDP
growth for an entire year and we can't
forget about Obama's terrible economy
millions more people on food stamps and
in poverty 95 million Americans out of
the labor force the worst economic
recovery since the 40s the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s and the
list goes on worse recovery since the
40s lowest homeownership rate in 51
years and unlike Obama business
confidence is now soaring under
President Trump in fact the news is so
good that even the liberal New York
Times cannot even ignore this take a
look at this headline I didn't make it
up the Trump effect business
anticipating less regulation loosens the
purse strings this is exactly what we've
been seeing happening all across the
country you couple that with the
brand-new 1.5 trillion dollar tax plan
that is now taking effect of what you
have is a recipe for a Reagan style
economic explosion you the American
people you're beginning to see the
direct impact of this tax bill for
example companies like Boeing eight
Comcast Wells Fargo and Fifth Third Bank
or all announced employee bonuses or pay
increases following that bill that's
real money back in the pockets of the
Forgotten men and women that deserve it
in this country take a look for example
what happened over it yeah liberal CBS
News they had an accountant crunch the
numbers to see how the tax plan is going
to impact the middle class in this
country oh it didn't come out the way
they expected watch this we wanted to
see how folks will actually fare so we
asked households from three different
parts of the country to send us their
tax returns and that we had an account
and calculate how things will change for
each of them a single mother who rents a
home in Cary North Carolina her income
last year as an administrative assistant
was a little under $40,000 if she were
your client what would you tell her I
got good news to you Marcie you're
getting more money back next year amber
and Jason Edwards were also hoping for
some good news you know I hope it
alleviates you know pressure on the
middle class whether it does or not I
don't know I actually think they would
pay tax on about $12,000 more of income
but because of the lower rates they
actually end up saving a little bit of
money honestly I'm a little surprised
because well what you had said initially
you thought we were going to have a
higher tax bill right they're not the
only ones Melissa and Lane Lev also
expressed concern about next year's
taxes I
thinking they're gonna be higher overall
he estimates they'll be responsible for
nearly $13,000 less in taxes can I get
the accountants number after this so a
night so all three families that we
brought to you they're all going to see
a decrease in their taxes every single
one of those families will have more
money in their pocket next year look at
that all three families are saving money
the tax cut will help middle-class
families they desperately need it and by
the way the bill also gets rid of the
Obamacare individual mandate and it
opens up energy exploration and Anwar oh
the lifeblood of our economy more energy
independence and by the way long-term
secure jobs at high wages for Americans
and lower prices for the entire country
all good and when it comes to Isis
presidents from he is unleashed the US
military and as a result letting them
decide all but destroyed the terror
group look at these numbers from the
Department of Defense that the president
tweeted out the military under president
Trump's leadership has done more in 11
months to defeat Isis then Obama did
during his last 28 months and that's
just a small sample of president Trump's
many accomplishments for 2017 take a
look on your screen right there
here is a list of president Trump's
accomplishments for 2017 ask yourself
have you heard the mainstream media the
destroyed Trump media anybody on the
left any liberal ever mention any of
these things have you heard them talk
about how the president's accomplishment
and all these accomplishments have
positively impacted the country probably
not they want and have wanted from the
beginning the president to fell now this
is exactly why the media the pundits the
political elites are predicting a huge
massive Democratic landslide in November
this year in the midterms but before
they get too giddy too excited let's
keep this in mind well these are the
so-called same experts political experts
who also President Trump never stood a
chance so maybe they should put a little
bit of the pump on the brakes here and
not get so giddy as a matter of fact it
may turn out to be just the opposite
the
president by the way he has created what
I am calling a for a blueprint for
victory in 2018 I hope the Republicans
in Washington are paying attention now
they did get their act together in
December I do give them credit but they
need to do more they need to keep the
momentum going
tax cuts that's a great start but they
need to keep for example like building
the wall finish repealing the disaster
that is Obamacare keep that promise or
replace it with free market solutions
healthcare savings accounts health care
cooperatives they should also pass
welfare reform it's desperately needed
again they should cut other wasteful
government spending programs we know the
Democrats they're signaling that they
want all kinds of concessions in these
upcoming negotiations in coming weeks
Republicans you need to show some
backbone at least for once stand up for
principles get your identity back and
here's why you always get the tax cut
you never get the tax cut you always get
the tax hike you never get the future
spending cuts we always get the
immediate concession or amnesty but you
never get the border wall built you
never get the border security
so you're Republicans you need to take
this past approach and flip it upside
down because so far it fails every time
so the GOP you want to win in November
you need to demand that things like the
border wall will get built and built
first before anything else can happen as
it relates to immigration now the
American people they need to see to 300
miles of this border wall built before
the election that will help you
politically and it's good for our
security and the same goes with other
issues that's the blueprint politically
for success in 2018 in the midterms and
Republicans you follow that you'll be
successful also tonight if 2017 is
defined by any one thing it will be the
news media's epic fail what are we here
all last year the entire year from the
mainstream liberal media Russia
collusion collusion collusion Russia
Russia Russia
well that fake news narrative is pretty
much completely blown up in their faces
after a year of non-stop breathless
reporting anonymous sources has
area on their part but there's so far up
to today zero evidence of collusion
between President Trump and the Russians
so now the media they've got a latch on
to something quick they're not going to
admit they're wrong so the new narrative
of the liberal media is that
conservatives actually hate the FBI they
hate law enforcement because of the bias
that we're exposing in the Russia
investigation watch this it is
astounding to see conservatives acting
like the FBI of all organizations is
some kind of indifference they stay you
know horror show the message is don't
look at or think about what may be under
investigation
let's find whatever we can to undermine
the pillars of the respect that we tend
to confer upon institutions like the FBI
and the Justice Department there's only
one institution that really has been
tainted through these months and that is
the Trump presidency it's tainted by the
president's lies by his disrespect for
American institutions operating under
the law the career civil servants at the
FBI and in the intelligence community
are working as hard as ever but this
can't be good for morale well that's the
new narrative conservatives this is
laughable Republicans hate law
enforcement and you know why it's
laughable because the liberal media
they're not the people that respect law
and law enforcement and they've been
that way for decades we'll explain in a
second but first I want to educate all
my failing colleagues in the media that
have been wrong so often now if you had
any sense of real law and order and our
constitutional republic you might
investigate Hillary Clinton and yeah the
numerous felonies we know she committed
if you care about it you should maybe
look into our top aide oh my a body and
our criminally miss handling on
classified information and those emails
and if you in the media if you really
cared about truth at all maybe look into
this and that's Muller's merry band of
democratic donors
let's see contributed only the democrats
politicians like obama and hillary in
the DNC imagine for a second if it was a
bunch of Republican donors that were
investigating through a special counsel
Hillary Clinton yeah you guys in the
media
you would be foaming at the mouth on a
nightly basis and if the media if you're
interested in truth when he asked why
Hillary Clinton and the Obama
administration why would they ever do
something really stupid and give 20% of
America's uranium supply to Russia yeah
that Russia Putin's Russia the adversary
the bad actor Russia won by the way we
don't even have enough uranium as it is
and maybe you'd follow the money if it
was Donald Trump and a hundred and forty
five million dollars pouring into the
Clinton Foundation and her coffers while
she's Secretary of State from the very
people involved in this particular deal
again if it was Donald Trump I know
you'd be all over it and of course you
would want to know
Oh was there a quid pro quo is that pay
to play but of course you don't want to
know that truth now let's go back to
this new narrative that's coming from
the fake news media that conservatives
hate the FBI the exact opposite is true
now on this show if you have watched ism
now my 23rd year I have always respected
the men and women in law enforcement
policemen firemen paramedics
I respect the intelligence community and
of course the FBI and even the CIA yes I
respect the hard work they do and now
the biased press they're the ones who
have this history of utter disdain for
members of law enforcement for example
it wasn't that long ago the media was
trashing police member how many of them
supported black lives matter you may
remember this is a great invention it's
called videotape but can remind you
thousands of Americans are marching in
New York and Washington and across the
country demanding a justice system that
applies the same to everybody and honors
our values and you we want you to know
that our hearts are out there marching
with them many African American people
said look we were introduced to terror
long before 9/11 the vicious police
forces of America that have victimized
us and the win which white supremacy
operated what's flared up in Baltimore
has heightened awareness once again of
this issue of police brutality yes
Baltimore alleged police brutality we
have repeatedly said on this show that
we have the utmost respect we praised
law enforcement the FBI the intelligence
community the issue we have in this
particular case this case is very
specific because you have a few
select people that have shown a very
anti-trump political bias so we have to
ask the media a couple of questions do
you support people like Peter struck the
guy that hates Trump loves Hillary the
FBI agent involved in everything and his
FBI lawyer girlfriend Lisa page together
by the way they call President Trump
just about every single swear word that
I can even think of and I swear
and by the way attack Trump and their
supporters they also texted about an
insurance policy in Andy's office which
we think of course is deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe in case Donald
Trump actually pulled off the impossible
and won the election so new media people
do you support people like the disgraced
former FBI director Comey admitted under
oath to having his friend leak
information to the New York Times in the
hopes that would bring about a special
counsel which it did and Comey also
likely broke the law writing his Trump
notes on FBI computers and then by the
way removing that government property
from the bureau
and by the way he exonerated Hillary
Clinton this is my favorite in the email
investigation before he ever did the
investigation i'm sure if that was
against hillary you guys would be pretty
upset and then of course Muller's team
of liberal donations as we have told you
over fifty thousand dollars his team has
donated over the years to democrats and
by the way none to president Trump one
of mullahs top investigators jeanne ray
represented the Clinton Foundation
during a 2015 racketeering case I guess
she's not biased and then you got Andrew
Weissman he's the guy that oversaw the
highly controversial obstruction of
justice case against Arthur Andersen and
by the way it destroyed the company cost
tens of thousands of jobs in 2005 the US
Supreme Court turned over Wiseman's
conviction a nine zero unanimous ruling
and it's part of the Enron investigation
Weitzman also sent for Merrill Lynch
executives to jail that conviction was
also overturned by the fifth US Circuit
Court of Appeals
that's Muller's team and next you have
demoted DOJ official Bruce Oren his wife
Nelly Bruce or met with Fusion GPS you
know those officials that came up with
the phony Russian propaganda
dossier that we now know his own wife
was working on the opposition against
Donald Trump that produced and bought
and paid for that fake news Russia
propaganda sounds like collusion to me
and finally of course the deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe his wife Jill
took over a half a million dollars from
Clinton ally former Governor Terry
McAuliffe and Democrats for a failed
Virginia state Senate seat that's an
insane amount of money McCabe is also
directly tied well like so many others
to the dossier and or a recent testimony
on Capitol Hill McCabe conflicted
statements from previous witnesses and
also claimed not to know when he found
out the Clintons and the DNC funded the
dossier and according to reports McCabe
is expected to retire next year with a
big fat taxpayer pension does any of
this matter to you in the liberal
mainstream media or do you just like to
fail and be wrong every day you know are
you supporting all these people you're
supporting that conduct you're
supporting that political bias you don't
see a conflict of interest do you really
think that this isn't corruption at the
highest level you know these criticisms
that we are making these are facts
they're not about institutions they're
about the violation of constitutional
rights and the abuse of power at the top
levels of our government this is serious
and we've been right you've been wrong
and finally tonight three major foreign
policy stories North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un is threatening the United States
by saying that a nuclear button is
always on his desk and that he has
nuclear weapons that can now reach the
United States President Trump just about
well 45 minutes ago fired back on
Twitter saying well he has an even
bigger nuclear button and his actually
works we'll have more on that later and
President Trump was also putting
Pakistan on notice by tweeting and
calling them out for helping terrorists
and not fully cooperating with the
United States he's right on that point
and also finally a major story protests
continuing tonight to breakout in Iran
so far twenty people have been killed
over 450 people have been arrested these
are people that are revolting against
this repressive regime and these radical
mullahs in Tehran it's something the
president Trump actually predicted
happen back in September now the mullahs
are scared out of their minds and this
is now the opportunity of a lifetime for
the people of Iran that have been
oppressed people that are getting killed
for being gay and lesbian women that are
treated horribly they can be free of
these radical dictators